la compra de la dotana ha llegado a su
fin una reunión que en muchos casos se
ha considerado histórica y que marca Su
futuro un futuro por cierto muchísimo
más incierto la organización como una
decenex ha vuelto a encontrar su razón
de ser que es la de proteger las
fronteras frente a un adversario que de
hecho conoce muy bien Rusia que en tan
solo 10 años ha pasado de ser un socio
estratégico ahora considerarse La
amenaza Más directa y más importante
para la seguridad de la alianza por ello
la organización ha anunciado un refuerzo
nunca visto desde la Guerra Fría en todo
el flanco Oriental además también se
ayudará más a Ucrania con un paquete de
ayuda financiera y militar por cierto
Estados Unidos ha anunciado una nueva
ayuda de 800 millones de dólares En
definitiva la otan se prepara y encara
una década convulsa y en que Estados
Unidos a pesar de que nunca se fue está
más presente que nunca en el continente